uh
the other thing is a lot of your
the reviews say that you don't
talk about the womanizing right
um
i found a lot of references in here are
you surprised when you read that that
you
in your reviews that this book doesn't
deal with womanizing
uh
i i actually have been mildly surprised
by that but of course it doesn't deal
with womanizing because most of the
other books are on womanizing that's
about all they're about my major take on
it was one
uh
people who
live that kind of life have to lie all
the time so the part of the facility is
a liar
comes from
comes from covering up uh clandestine
affairs of
of some sort and that it was incredibly
corrupting i thought
i think that to him
it was like uh tennis in a way and and
it took less time than scheduling tennis
games but the logistics were a heck of a
lot more uh complicated so that everyone
up to dean rusk
had to run these operations with
helicopters and cars and whatever to get
women here and there
and then they'd be with kennedy for 12
minutes or something and uh they were
gone and he was
with and many of these people were proud
to do that because they felt that it it
was a right of initiation they had been
brought in they were closer
that corruption of his own people and
breaking them essentially
many of them
was what i found interesting and
significant about the womanizing the
fact of it itself
i didn't uh
it had it had to do with lying and with
the corruption of other people
where it was important we were talking
about daisy buchanan in a way and in the
great gatsby this the this rich boy does
whatever he wants and there are people
there to clean up the mess whether it
involves paying off people or
whatever it takes and that john kennedy
at least to me is pretty unattractive
here's a page you've got pictures of
several of the women that were
supposedly in his life
this is ben bradley's former foreign law
mary meyer
and judith exner next to her ryan that
is not what you'd affectionate looked
like of course when
this was all happening and then down
below that you have marilyn monroe and
jane mansfield no andrew dickens angie
dickinson uh how do you know
i mean well how do you you've got a
footnote back here you've got a book
that you refer to in the book
about fiddle and fatal two of what
secretaries that work for that's what
they refer to james uh gigolo that was
the name
okay he's a professor
i use that for a particular reason but
yes uh but how how can you be sure of
all these stories that they're accurate
and then you list a lot of other names
tempest storm blaze star you had
relations with those people that was
according i didn't use that in the book
i mean that's according to gigalog uh
the uh i start started with uh
airplane logs and and coming and going
logs
uh beginning with the inauguration when
angie dickinson was with him during the
uh
uh the inaugural
uh after uh after mrs kennedy went home
uh and a lot of up to the point
uh
in some cases some people
told me particularly uh grand women in
this
uh in this city
but the uh
uh none of the people i don't know about
uh blaise storm and whatnot giglio's
list although he's a very respected
uh teacher and whatnot but the people i
use in the book either i was totally
satisfied
that they were telling the truth or
people who handled the logistics of
moving them in and out were telling the
truth
and there were uh there were a number
but i
part of me
wanted to
the whole idea of the book was to what
it's like to be president
what a president does how it how it
feels only 42 people know
and i did not want to get myself drowned
by uh
by what was in some ways
the least interesting part
of his life and a relatively small part
although
it would be foolish to ignore it or to
pretend it didn't happen